hey folks Danny here with another
gamespot news update today Microsoft
Studios executive Phil Spencer has
acknowledged the Microsoft could have
done a better job handling the messaging
surrounding the Xbox ones earlier
controversial policies fans will know
that recall the original xbox one
announcement in May was muddied with
controversy I bet the platform's online
requirements and even more drama came to
light when microsoft revealed its
divisive used games policy at e3 in June
Microsoft reversed most of these
policies prior to the launch of the Xbox
one notably dropping the requirement
that the console be connected to the
internet once per day and fully allowing
used games to work on the system now
Spencer and other xbox executives have
made a conscious effort to be
increasingly active on Twitter and other
social networks which was an intentional
effort to better connect with fans
Spencer said one of the reasons I wanted
to be a little more active socially was
because I knew the core of why we were
in the industry was not an evil reason
it was to really delight consumers and
build a great product that millions and
millions of people would love he
continued when you're going to say
something to a consumer that might put
them off it's better to just be direct
and honest rather than trying to
sugarcoat something that might be
controversial for more news about xbox
one and Phil Spencer social life stay
tuned to gamespot com